[Music]
okay everybody so this is my spoiler
review of episode five of severance the
grim barbarity of optics and design this
is again directed by ifa mcardle and
written by anna manch so actually my
favorite moment in this episode is the
amazing intro sequence here i love the
piano playing in the background of it
sounds like something out of a radiohead
album which i really appreciated and it
fit this scene so well here just eerie
but tragic and we see that audi heli
recognizes again that she went up in the
elevator that she's hanging
and then we know both versions of audis
are tough they're gonna just fight to
the death literally here and the
elevator ends up going back down so it
was a message that helie was sending to
her audi but i do believe that you know
the heli workily wanted her to go out
like that like she says later in the
episode that she wanted to be the one to
tell her audi self like i'm the one who
like ended you but it wasn't successful
but i love how mark panics when he sees
her in the elevator and the security guy
just throws him in the elevator and
immediately he forgets when he gets up
the elevator i thought that was such a
cool effect and taking advantage of the
awesome stuff they already set up in
this world so again just a great open
and it gets crazier because the next day
at work when he comes down the elevator
he immediately continues where he left
off in panic that's the cool thing about
this show is that even though they
forget stuff when they leave when they
come back it's like a continuation
directly where they left off and i keep
talking about all the themes they got
going out just about corporate buildings
we work in how the corporate world
functions and the messed up stuff they
do you see more of that here just where
mark's like is she okay helly is she
gonna have time off you're gonna let her
go and harmony's like her audi has no
intention of leaving she'll be back at
her desk in a few days and he's like is
that enough time so this is again
something i think we can all relate to
the office maybe even ourselves where
someone's suffering at work and they get
little time off and there's really not
actual true care from the higher-ups
about their well-being it's just back to
work as usual and i know this took a
while for me to just notice but this
clicked in my head just how many times
especially this episode they emphasized
where the higher-ups and the security
guy everyone's saying their names with
their last initial so she's like this
happened on your watch mark s and the
security man later will say helly r
really intensely so you know it really
lends to the theory in my head like okay
if they're really emphasizing that last
initial they wouldn't have to say that
every time unless there wasn't other
versions of them whether it's a clone
or it's just everyone who is a man maybe
and the certain type of man in that
building is named mark and they have to
separate them or vice versa with heli as
the woman in the building i'm not sure
about that it could be clones who knows
but there's got to be super significance
to why they have to emphasize the last
name now scene i also loved when mark is
reading ricken's book the uur again in
the bathroom and we're getting the
themes of the show here but we're also
getting some humor blended in and i love
the lines where rick and right to
society with festering workers cannot
flourish what separates man from
machines that machines cannot think for
themselves this was actually great and
is so true and he's talking about
inspiring fellow soldiers at work by you
making this the leap right a good person
will follow the rules a great person
will follow himself again great stuff
here and we'll see this happen in this
episode and it happens both ways because
by mark seeing helly's behavior in the
office it is in a sense subconsciously
inspiring him that something's up here
something has to change so that will go
the other way too where by the end of
the episode heli is inspired by mark so
it is really just rounded out really
well with the themes they bring up even
an episode and getting payoff later on
in the same episode but when i'm talking
about the humor it is rick and we're
talking about heroes a lot of humor in
this episode he's a great character but
of the lines like bullies are nothing
but bulls and lies and at the center of
industry is dust
they can't crucify your hand if it's in
a fist like you know again it's good
stuff but it's funny like it's funny how
he's pointing it out in the words i
thought that was great so we learned
that harmony hasn't told the board about
what happens with heli and we also
learned the security guy has given her
the chip back it's confirmed that pd
chip was messed with it was reintegrated
but she doesn't want to show us to the
board until she has everything she needs
she wants to know who did this now this
person has to be the person calling mark
with the blocked phone number so that's
gonna be a big reveal of who's behind
the kind of revolt here of the company
and harmony's character got even more
fascinating this episode because she is
not someone who is gonna bow down to the
people above her even and she's starting
to go her own independent way of the
company's values and more towards the
values that she's justifying through
here originally and using a lot of his
passages so it's not for good it's just
a different way it's her way she's a
rebel in her own sense but i think she's
actually gonna end up being worse than
even the people who are running the
place now now we see mark is leaving
from a panicky situation with helly and
he's going to his audi and he's in
another situation that's intense where
he's got all these missed calls from
ricken and his sister devin is having
contractions and this baby's coming soon
and it's interesting where they are in
this cabin at this big retreat that they
get this big map mark that he sees and
it reminds me even of the map a little
bit of the office so they made a kind of
a big point of that so that was had to
mean something and there's a lot of
weird stuff going on in this retreat
area with the cabins there's more than
meets the eye because when devon goes to
get coffee she sees the other bigger
cabin with this wealthier couple
and you know she sees this pregnant
woman named gabby drinking coffee she's
all in white but then we could assume as
her husband is but maybe not but he's
just a man all in white and she yells
for him and he just runs away and goes
off screens we don't even see his face
so something is up there and there's a
painting in their cabin that looks like
a maze so there's definitely gonna be
more with this gabby character and there
is something about even where they are i
think there's just layers and layers to
this show and starting to kind of hint
at that and i love that rickon cries
over devin here and is like i don't want
to be like my father that was great and
rickon wants you know he believes in
telling a big secret for good luck right
for the baby and this leads to what i
predicted that you know was going to
come up the book that why didn't mark
reach out to them about the book they
were going to get curious about that and
he's heard about it and then rickon
wants mark's help to help him hang kelp
so i googled hanging kelp there's not
really much on it sometimes it was to
predict if it was gonna rain or not but
that's really all i found so it might
just be something silly they're putting
with rick and who knows and rickon's
obsessed now about knowing this book is
missing it's an advanced copy right it
really is becoming his main annoyance
even though his wife's about to give
labor he's still so worried about it and
he's like if the thief reads it he will
turn himself in at least so that's
interesting line because it's just kind
of playing on that the people reading it
at lumen the power of his book will get
them to revolt right it's the same
concept that it's going to change these
people it's a powerful book and changing
you as a person your philosophy so we
know dylan we know mark are reading that
book so that's just going to add more
and more to their workies and what they
plan on doing it's like the opposite of
the cure bible for the higher ups and
little things are important too even
though we're kind of slower in the
episode where his sister is you know
encouraging alexa her friend for mark
still and that's important because alexa
is gonna be a key to mark getting over
his wife and the trauma he felt and
that's a key then for him to be more
clear-headed and figure out what's
really going on at lumen and you see he
even says to devin i think lumen might
be up to something you remember the
businessman meaning petey and then devin
starts contracting at that moment and
marks out he starts thinking about pd
collapsing again and that blocked phone
number ringing so he's got to answer
that phone to make that next leap and
get out of denial right it's it's him
breaking through the trauma of his wife
instead of protecting that trauma and
living with it is letting it go facing
it and then that's part of that is
answering that phone not using lumen as
a disguise from that anymore and then
you hear faintly that the baby is born
as well that was a big thing because
they didn't show you that but she did
have the baby now the hardest i laughed
in this episode and in the show so far
was when milcheck tells mark you know
it's gonna be the first time helly is
conscious as her workie so he wants her
to see everyone really happy upbeat no
concern again just speaking to how
companies treat people who have
suffering with mental health stuff and
you know he's like i want you to make
your eyes kind do you know how to make
your eyes kind only adam scott could
pull this off the way he does it is so
funny and i love that he went back to it
when he first sees heli he tries doing
it it's just hysterical so what we're
talking about with harmony being
rebellious here to her own company's
values she is having miss casey observe
helly and see for signs of sadness but
you know this is where milchex kind of
like you know why are you doing that
like that's against the book you know
and he's more to the book mill check
where he's getting wind of a lot of
harmonies just doing things on her own
which could be a problem for harmony now
middle check later on but you'll see
harmony says that to milchik and the
security guard both of them in this
episode she quotes a passage from kier
and is saying things like virgin rivers
like new ideas new ways of doing things
she's doing it on her own merit here and
what i really like is how they revealed
now a big answer for the show so we're
getting a lot of answers even though we
get questions we get an answer to reward
us in the meantime which is good right
that's good mystery storytelling tv and
i love how they did this where milcheck
knew that irving was spending too much
time with bert and they were getting too
close so he has irving discover the
painting of the coup that supposedly
happened with o and d and the reveal of
the whole episode is that they had a
similar painting but different phones
right of mdr so both departments are
being brainwashed it's like propaganda
by the company to pin them against each
other they don't want these departments
bonding together to have a chance of
revolting against the higher ups so they
make up lies so that's a cool reveal
that no there wasn't really a coup there
wasn't these crazy things these
departments were doing that they were
hearing about they just didn't want any
departments coming together but you see
even the workers like you know miss
casey or for herself clearly don't want
to get in trouble because when helly
goes missing you know that's the reason
she tells irv that bert's in the
conference room because she knows that
will distract whoever's watching from
heli missing that she won't get in
trouble but the other twist is that
harmony was already watching anyway and
she let it go on because again she has
this chilling line where she's like the
surest way to tame a prisoner is let him
believe he is free so that's why i'm
talking about why i think she's kind of
being worse than even the higher ups at
lumen now but where mark starts to
really sound like the values in rickon's
book is when he says to helly when she's
talking about her audi telling her she's
not a person he's like don't focus on
her what do you want here so he's again
sounding like what he's learning from
the book here and also hypocrisy we see
is that the handbook frowns upon
colleagues being in relationships
together but you see that bert and irv
are looking at that painting of keir and
his wife and how they met and they
actually did meet in lumen but they made
it like they were bonded by the spirit
of industry which is ridiculous so it's
total hypocrisy and they make up these
values just so they can control people
now the thing that's going to get
everyone going crazy on reddit is this
room of baby goats and this guy is
giving a goat milk and he's like they're
not ready give me time and i like they
kind of had a meta thing here where
helly was like making a theory of her
own like is that what we're doing with
the scary numbers it probably isn't but
i think it also will be alluding to
people saying stuff like that but also
that she's aware of it and the audience
is clearly like those scary numbers are
doing something bad to something
somebody some type of creature or person
we just don't know yet but it can't be
the goats but i think that's kind of the
joke of it but there will be some
significance to that but by the end mark
wins over heli here about the map
recreating pd's map and now they're kind
of on the same page finally and they've
kind of inspired each other in a way to
kind of start being more curious about
what's going on with lumen but the
interesting twist of it all is again
that harmony is letting them see other
departments she's got some bigger plan
here so it's interesting what is
harmony's endgame so we get this ending
where now bert introduces dylan and irv
to the rest of the o and d department
and you know that's why you see on d
scared of them too because of the horror
stories they hear about each other but
this is huge and it even converted dylan
now that he's seen the truth so it's
exactly what lumen doesn't want they
don't want these departments even
becoming friends and it's going to be
interesting i feel like they're setting
up something tragic here with bert and
irv because too much is going in their
way in a sense and they're falling in
love and it makes you wonder if those
two will even survive the first season
it might just be a sad ending for them
that's one of my main predictions right
now but we'll see but i'm giving this
one a 9.2 it wasn't as good as maybe the
last two episodes but it's still really
solid and it felt like kind of a
transitional episode meaning it was now
setting up some new threads here and
giving us new answers and you're like
okay now we're really going into like
revolt setting up now of more awareness
by our workers in lumen and we're
getting more reveals about harmony and
that there's going to be layers to this
story and layers to this world
especially what's going on with that
shady retreat with all the cabins so
we'll see i'm still so hooked i'm
excited this was still really great like
i said a 9.2 the writing is solid the
acting is amazing cinematography is
still great and i'm still on the edge of
my seat the whole time let me know what
you guys thought down below i'd love to
hear your thoughts i read every comment
try to respond as many as i can please
make sure to subscribe if you don't miss
one of my reviews of severance i also do
movie reviews celebrity interviews as
well please follow me at steve varley
show on twitter instagram and tick tock
for more of me and i'll see you next
time